die whu teil dieser woche mit die korona
krise spitzt sich zu also jetzt aktuell
nicht mehr in europa aber im rest der
welt
speziell als deutscher kann man sich das
kaum vorstellen
wir glauben ja immer mehr menschen krone
haben wir hinter uns wenn ich mir zum
beispiel die bilder aus berlin angucke
wo gerade für die club szene
demonstriert wurde
die emo das war einfach nur ein
schlauchboot idioten party wenn sie mich
altmodisch aber für mich ist besoffen im
gummiboot liegen kein politisches
statement anderswo zieht corona das
tempo gewaltig an in afrika zum beispiel
besonders schlimm ist die lage in
südamerika insbesondere in brasilien mit
über 800.000 infizierten und über 40.000
toten und dann werden die armen menschen
auch noch regiert vom sogenannten tropen
trump kabul szenario dreht inzwischen
völlig durch ist nicht übertrieben dreht
völlig durch auch wegen portion aros
corona kleinreden politik werden in sao
paulo und anderswo massengräber
ausgehoben ist eine absolute tragödie
sein kommentar okay es ist gerade diese
typen wie dieser bastard von gouverneur
von sao paulo oder der bürgermeister von
manaus wollen von dem virus profitieren
es kotzt mich an dass sie solche
gemeinschaftsgräber schaffen
sie wollen uns unsere freiheiten bastard
geht es nicht etwas niveauvoller möchte
man das blöde arschloch fragen aber wozu
wozu jetzt will auch noch aus der whu
austreten sogar das wahrzeichen von rio
ist entsetzt
entsetzt und enttäuscht genau das
passiert wenn populisten regieren
betrifft übrigens portion als gesamtes
kabinett und dann schockiert
ausgerechnet der umweltminister mit
seinem plan gerade jetzt die abholzung
des regenwaldes zu erleichtern
jetzt wo wir gerade ruhe haben weil sich
die presse nur mit kuwait 19 beschäftigt
sollten wir den moment nutzen um die
vereinfachung der ganzen regeln und
normen voranzubringen alter wo du da
rein sprichst das nennt man mikro und
das links von ihr ist eine kamera
wir können dich sehen und hören ist
einfach unfassbar diese regierung ball
zu nahrung unfassbar und getan wie
gesagt allein im april sind am amazonas
64 prozent mehr bäume verschwunden als
im april des vorjahres
die ziehen das durch
finden ein wussten sie eigentlich dass
klaus kinski mal in den achtzigern den
noch blutjungen ball szenario getroffen
hat
regenwald hier hat sie das gelernte
wissen du vorne elektrisch doch am arsch
bett der total wichtige funktion fürs
weltklima und das know-how austreten was
soll das denn so verdammt blöd kann ja
nicht mal du dein bruder esau da schön
zusammengefasst kroner wäre jedenfalls
an sich eine prima gelegenheit für
reiche länder den ärmeren ja regelrecht
zu helfen zum beispiel bangladesch dem
land in dem unsere billigklamotten
genäht werden
seit jahren bangladesch musste
allerdings in den letzten wochen
schmerzhaft erfahren was unser einst
unter solidarität in krisenzeiten genau
versteht die internationalen modemarken
haben plötzlich ihre aufträge
zurückgezogen im wert von mehr als drei
milliarden us-dollar davon betroffen
sind in bangladesch ganz direkt mehr als
1000 fabriken mit mehr als zwei
millionen arbeitern ja selbst bereits
produzierte ware haben die stumpf nicht
bezahlt ganz oben in der liste der
größten stornieren bis mitte märz
primark und c&a zwar steht vorübergehend
beurlaubt ein arbeiter in bangladesch
ein teil lohn zu aber 98 prozent der
auftraggeber haben sich daran einfach
nicht beteiligt wir haben kurzarbeit die
harmonie das ist der unterschied
inzwischen ist die produktion teilweise
wieder angelaufen aber natürlich oft
unter völliger missachtung der
hygieneregeln
was ist mit uns zählen unsere leben
licht warum kümmert sich niemand um uns
wir sind doch auch menschen in der
vorzeige fabrik läuft zu besser aber die
ist ja auch zum vorzeigen ja macht auf
eine zynische art sogar sind fast schon
beeindruckend wie wir es immer wieder
schaffen solche fakten auszublenden wenn
wir uns die nächste billig buchse kaufen
ja auch deutsche konzerne müssen endlich
mehr verantwortung übernehmen für die
zustände am anfang ihrer lieferketten
warte mal hatte sich unsere groko dazu
nicht ganz fest ein neues gesetz
vorgenommen
zunächst hieß das vorhaben
wertschöpfungsketten gesetz eine erste
längst überholte skizze erzürnt die
wirtschaft immer noch weil darin von
bußgeldern
harten strafen für unternehmen die rede
war was strafen wenn man sich dann ein
gesetzlich hält eine bizarre idee wo
kommen wir da hin
endlich sollte der gesetzentwurf schon
im letzten märz vorgestellt werden aber
das hat dann wohl jemand von ganz oben
ausgebremst und zwar war das
wahrscheinlich die angela rogalla angela
angela findet wahrscheinlich wir sollten
unsere textilindustrie nicht unnötig
belasten mit menschenrechten und so
gedöns findet die industrie selbst
übrigens auch wir haben uns als
wirtschaft klar dafür ausgesprochen
keine zusätzlichen belastungen in dieser
sehr schwierigen corona bedingten phase
vorzunehmen das wäre auch der falsches
falsche signal
ein ganz falsches signal verstehen sie
was er da sagt deren geschäftsmodell
rechnet sich offenbar nur mit massiver
ausbeutung am anderen ende der welt
dann wird es nicht entwicklungsminister
gerd müller würde das gerne ändern aber
wie viel hat er zu melden in dieser
region und wahrscheinlich nicht allzu
viel
laut einer studie der eu-kommission
würde das umsetzen von mindest standards
in der produktion große firmen im
schnitt nur 0,005 prozent ihrer gewinne
kosten
falsche signal fazit ein richtiges
lieferketten gesetz muss endlich her
die passende petition finden sie unter
lieferketten gesetz de oder tun wir den
modekonzern hier unrecht
[Musik]
guten tag mein name heißt denis ich bin
das neue werbegesicht von primark ja
aber ganz wichtig prime mark mit ai und
ca das ist der billigableger der
nobelmarke primark ja aber die ist nur
was für reiche leute so willst du so
angeber mit richtig kohle so die chance
die aber egal ich rede jetzt in eine
andere kamera und mache ein sehr ernstes
gesicht nicht nur in bangladesch
was ist das eigentlich bangladesch ist
ein geräusch oder was was ein land auch
so ein land
okay nicht nur in bangladesch auch die
deutsche mode branche braucht dringend
hilfe
unsere lager ja die platzen aus allen
nähten die herzliche frühjahrskollektion
liegt ja auch noch um wegen dem corona
aber der sommer krempel der kommt ja
auch schon rein und du musst hier aus
sehen wir platzen aus allen nähten mit
dem ganzen klamotten
er kann aber auch die autos was das ist
die neue prime markt juni waren
was für ein inspirierender ob anna style
fensters amazing alter er ich sehe aus
wie ein opfer aus ägypten vertrieben
kann das sein können die ganzen dosen
kinder bitte wieder in unsere läden
kommt um irgendwas zu kaufen
ihr müsst ihr sein ja auch nicht
anziehen groß es ist doch grillsaison
gutachten ein sack voll als billigen
kohle absatz an schulen und würstchen
drei feuer arbeit zu nennen wir das
selber verbrennen ja kostet das 120 euro
pro tonne
ja dafür kriegt man bei 3 markt 120
hosen los kauft die jetzt sonst war die
ganze ausbeute in dem bangladesch
umsonst
ich hab schon wieder gesagt das klingt
wie bangladesch wie so ein geräusch als
ob eine wand gelaufen ist
ja ich gehe ja
[Musik]
ja it service provider sprechen mit
jürgen wie kann ich ihnen weiterhelfen
haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus und
wieder einzuschalten hat nichts gebracht
verstehe ja probieren sie doch mal den
kanal der heute show auf youtube zu
abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung